Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
If you start watching reviews of some of the
more recent smartphones, you will almost always
see a dedicated section to low-light photography.
The result is almost always that cameras that
work remarkably well in well-lit scenes produce
almost unusable results in dim environments.
So unless we have access to a super expensive
camera, what can we really do to obtain more
usable low-light images?
Well, of course, we could try brightening
the image up by increasing the exposure.
This would help maybe a tiny bit, but would
also mess up our white balance and also amplify
the noise within the image.
I hope that by now you are getting the feeling
that there must be a better AI-based solution.
Let's have a look!
This is an image of a dark indoor environment,
I am sure you have noticed.
This was taken with a relatively high light
sensitivity that can be achieved with a consumer
camera.
This footage is unusable.
And this image was taken by an expensive camera
with extremely high light sensitivity settings.
This footage is kinda usable, but is quite
dim and is highly contaminated by noise.
And now, hold on to your papers, because this
AI-based technique takes sensor data from
the first, unusable image, and produces this.
Holy smokes!
And you know what the best part is?
It produced this output image in less than
a second.
Let's have a look at some more results.
These look almost too good to be true, but
luckily, we have a paper at our disposal so
we can have a look at some of the details
of the technique!
It reveals that we have to use a Convolutional
Neural Network to learn the concept of this
kind of image translation, but that also means
that we require some training data.
The input should contain a bunch of dark images,
these are the before images, this can hardly
be a problem, but the output should always
be the corresponding image with better visibility.
These are the after images.
So how do we obtain them?
The key idea is to use different exposure
times for the input and output images.
A short exposure time means that when taking
a photograph, the camera aperture is only
open for a short amount of time.
This means that less light is let in, therefore
the photo will be darker.
This is perfect for the input images as these
will be the ones to be improved.
And the improved versions are going to be
the images with a much longer exposure time.
This is because more light is let in, and
we'll get brighter and clearer images.
This is exactly what we're looking for!
So now that we have the before and after images
that we referred to as input and output, we
can start training the network to learn how
to perform low-light photography well.
And as you see here, the results are remarkable.
Machine learning research at its finest.
I really hope we get a software implementation
of something like this in the smartphones
of the near future, that would be quite amazing.
And as we have only scratched the surface,
please make sure to look at the paper as it
contains a lot more details.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!